hello this is dr. Gerald Dirks formerly
the Reverend Gerald Dirk's in just a few
moments here on the Dean show we'll be
talking about my conversion to Islam
please don't go away
this will add hamdulillah assalamu
alaikum which is a greeting of peace
peace be unto you welcome to another
episode of the Deen show where we're
here trying to help you understand Islam
and Muslims and when we come back we
have a very special guest who was a
former Christian minister he has
graduated with honors from the
prestigious Harvard University with a
master's in divinity started studying
the Bible at a very young age he has so
much to share with us today on the Deen
show and I'm so excited to have him here
with us so you don't want to go nowhere
we're gonna be talking to dr. Gerald
Dirk's when we come back here on the
Dean show you don't want to go nowhere
we'll be right back
is his messenger Allah
there's only one Jesus was his messenger
no I did that maybe it maybe it's just
to break the ice
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam how are
you brother
alhamdulillah thank you so much for
taking the time out of your busy
schedule to come and visit us here at
the deans house my pleasure brother we
have got to mention a few things about
you you were actually a former minister
a deacon ordained deacon in the United
Methodist Church and you have a master's
degree in divinity from Harvard
University from Harvard Divinity School
correct wow this is and the list goes on
you are were a preacher at many starting
at a young age you worked as a youth
minister ordained minister and the list
goes on you we have some books also here
that you have authored yes we're gonna
mention through the books here you have
the Abraham the front of God which is
this book here well it's actually the
Abrahamic faith the Abrahamic faiths you
have easy to understand Islam it's
another book here we have Muslims in
America the history yeah and you have
letters to my elders in Islam yes you
have understanding Islam now you've
wrote written a lot of books on Islam
and the crescent and the cross the cross
and the crescent you like to write huh
so these are some of your books that
you've authored you you're obviously
very busy writing books you you are out
there trying to now mend the bridges
build the bridges to help develop a
better understanding between Islam the
Muslims and people of other faiths but
we want to hear about your story we want
to know why would someone who was so
high up in the ranks who had so much
knowledge of Christianity you know the
Bible well what happened let's
from your we'll get a little bit of a
history from a young age talk to us tell
us how you got involved in Christianity
and your parents and exceptions sure
actually there's probably four parts to
the story yes and the first part would
be sort of my journey into the Christian
ministry yeah the second part would be
my leaving the ministry third part would
be my years as what I called in a
typical Christian yeah and then finally
the fourth part my journey into Islam
but you asked about the first part which
is my sort of journey and to the
Christian ministry yes I grew up in a
small rural community in Kansas where
the church was the center of community
life it was a small town of about 500
people we had three churches every
summer there were ice cream socials at
the church's chicken pot pie dinners
cornrows etc and the churches really
were the center of community life and
that was true for my family as well we
attended the local Methodist Church and
throughout my childhood I was very
actively involved in collecting my
perfect attendance pens from Sunday
School my Awards for memorizing biblical
verses etc and so by the time I reached
junior high school I was already
considering the ministry as a personal
calling and about that time during the
annual Youth Sunday I was always
selected to deliver the sermon and word
of that got around and before long I was
preaching at various other local
churches upon occasion at nursing homes
at various church affiliated
organizations etc cold was a set I was
probably about 14 when this started very
young as yeah and so I continued in that
direction and at age 17 I entered
Harvard College as an undergraduate with
a philosophy major which was gearing
towards sin
and continued on in that direction
in 1970 actually 1969 I received my
license to preach from the United
Methodist Church in 1971 graduated as an
undergraduate and entered Harvard
Divinity School which is a three-year
program leading to a degree in Master of
Divinity in 1972 I was ordained a deacon
in the United Methodist Church and in
1974 I graduated with a Master of
Divinity from Harvard Divinity School
spent that summer as an interim minister
into rural parishes in Kansas but in the
fall of 1974 I left the ministry or at
least left the parish ministry I was
still an ordained minister but never
again what I fill a pulpit after the
fall of 1974 which probably brings us to
the second part of the story if you want
to move in that direction yeah tell us
what will you go into that why did you
end up I mean you were filling the
pulpits I mean did you have like a big
crowd people would be excited to come
listen to you preach and did you guys
have a band how did that work to
describe this this atmosphere oh well at
the risk of sounding immodest yeah
typically everywhere I preached we said
attendance records you were like a Jimmy
Swaggart at the time I mean of your
community maybe a Joel Olsteen Oh of the
the small little town or well I I don't
want to do comparisons but yeah suffice
it to say attend is typically
skyrocketed
oh when when I was behind the pulpit so
people know who you were yes they wanted
you they wanted a ticket to get into
this church to see and to hear what you
had to say because you had knowledge you
were a man of knowledge amongst other
things yeah okay so talk to us now from
filling the pulpits people lined up
wanting to hear what you have to say
from preaching the Bible what now led
you to leave the pulpit well when people
ask me mm-hmm
hey I usually see there's a long story
in a short story yes the short story is
a good seminary education the long story
takes a little longer but basically it's
one of the ironies of life that the
churches often take the most promising
of their young ministers and they send
them to really good seminaries and in
those really good seminaries such as the
one I was fortunate enough to attend you
are systematically exposed to the oldest
existing texts of how the Bible actually
once read you're exposed to the changes
that were made in those texts when those
changes took place why those changes
took place where are those changes took
place so once you receive that knowledge
and those changes by the way raise
serious serious questions about such
fundamental Christian doctrines as the
Trinity the sonship of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him the crucifixion event
and the doctrine of atonement and the
blood all of these come into serious
question when you look at the oldest
manuscripts that we have of what the
Bible wants that so that was one
consideration the other consideration is
that you are also given a very good
grounding in the history of the early
church now this is seminary school yes
this is at when it when when does now
seminary school come is that that's
after Harvard now well first you do the
undergraduate I think four years
undergraduate at Harvard okay
receive my BA yes and then entered
Harvard Divinity School which is a
Seminary yes and that's a three-year
course of studies leading to a Master of
Divinity okay gotcha
so the second thing you're exposed to is
the actual history of the early
Christian Church
and in terms of that you're exposed to
the decidedly geopolitical machinations
that really went into the
finding some of the fundamental
doctrines and dogmas of Christianity and
notice I said geopolitical machinations
not theological considerations not
religious considerations but political
considerations that went in you're also
exposed to the tremendous breadth of
knowledge the tremendous breadth of
opinion that existed within early
Christianity you know it was not
monolithic this is not kind of like the
Christian Fick well suffice it to say
there were many different branches yeah
to early Christianity now the branch
that survived basically into modern
times was Pauline Christianity
this was the Christianity that developed
out of the teachings of Paul or Saul of
Tarsus this is what's mainstream today
yes basically yeah but there were many
other branches to early Christianity
some of which survived for centuries
before they eventually died out and one
of the fundamental distinctions that we
can make is between Pauline Christianity
which was the Christianity that Paul
took to the Gentiles and the non-jews
principally in Europe but also to a
certain extent in Asia Minor and we can
contrast that with what's called the
Jerusalem church now this was the actual
disciples of Jesus yes and how they
practiced and what they believed and
there were decided differences between
these two groups but over time because
of geopolitical considerations the
different branches of Christianity was
sort of systematically eliminated one by
one and when that was done unfortunately
that was done often at the expense of
destroying books there were much
considered Scripture by some of these
branches of Christianity so a lot of
knowledge was lost in the destruction of
these books but these are the two
fundamental reasons why I left the
Christian ministry it really boiled down
to an issue
personal integrity mmm you know how can
I stand behind the pulpit on Sunday
morning and preach a sermon that I knew
was at variance with the actual taproot
of Christianity
of course if I stood behind the pulpit
on Sunday morning and preached what I
had been taught in seminary I'd be
looking for a new job within a week yeah
so this conflict existed and as a result
to preserve my personal integrity
I left the act of ministry and pursued
graduate school in clinical psychology
and by the way approximately half of my
graduating class from Harvard Divinity
School walked away from the parish
ministry upon graduation so I wasn't the
only one is this kind of like the have
you heard of Bart arum yes yes kind of
people also who have gotten engrossed
and really started to go deeper into
studying the original text and many of
them they come to the conclusion that
you have that you know a lot of this
it's not making sense it doesn't sure
sure and you know the biblical scholar
you mentioned is a good example of that
but there are many others as well can
you name a few that Pete some people who
are out there that academics who they
recognize these people these names oh
well Bart Ehrman is certainly one but
it's really almost any good biblical
scholar
you know I mean all you have to do is
pick up a good Bible Commentary yeah
such as the interpreters Bible
commentary and begin reading it yeah and
you'll be exposed in the process to wait
a minute this text originally read this
way and this was inserted into the text
around the Year 380 in Spain this sort
of information is there it's available
to the public but they have to really go
out and study in order to find it that's
the thing how many actually want to take
the time to investigate instead of just
blindly going along with what everyone
else is going along yeah and it does
take a great deal of time yeah to try
and do it on here
uh-huh tell us did you feel now before
we move forward with the story did you
feel before you were engrossed with all
this new knowledge that you were
impervious to someone I was coming in
with other beliefs views opinions were
you really staunch in your belief that
it was unshakable before you got all
this new knowledge sure I mean I had
believed what I had been taught in
church in Sunday school probably just
like everyone else believes what they're
taught in church in Sunday school and so
it is a it's a real shock when all of a
sudden you're confronted with a text
that says you know and in these verses
of the Bible if you look at the original
text it raises real questions as to
whether or not Jesus was actually
crucified yeah that's a shock tell us
also who are you emulate who did you
feel you we all are emulating somebody
we have role models who are you before
emulating who are you trying to were you
trying to be like Jesus were you trying
to be like a certain pastor a preacher
well there are certainly ministers who
had an influence on me and ministers to
whom I looked up and admired certainly
the role model of Jesus peace be upon
him as is presented in the four Gospels
of the Bible it's a very powerful and
very positive role model yeah so that
was always there as well yeah tell us
now this is very interesting it's
intriguing I'm sure people's ears are
glued to the screen there's one thing I
just wanted to - have you comment on
because we want this those sincere and
honest people who are really wanting to
know the truth we want them to be able
to understand this but there are some
people who sometimes they just can't get
past certain things and they're looking
at your beard we want them to get past
the beard tell us about the beard for a
second well the beard for me is simply
following the example of Prophet
Muhammad who advised us in a hadith or
in us one of his sayings though that we
shouldn't trimmed
that we should let the beard grow so
with an advice from the Prophet peace be
upon him I let my beard grow didn't
Jesus have a beard well we assume so
didn't Moses have a beard well we assume
so beards beards were fashioned at that
time at that part of the world yeah
fashion has changed for people but for
what God has ordained through his
messengers as the teachers they were the
ones that we should be emulating isn't
it yes yet that is what remains state so
this is just a pious example of somebody
trying to emulate the best of human
beings these prophets yes would you say
okay so I hope that one person or two
they got past the gear now tell us
did you believe earnestly with full
conviction that the Bible was the Word
of God Almighty before again you got
engrossed in all this new knowledge well
I think we have to define what's meant
by the Word of God
yes there's two main beliefs that run
throughout Christianity if you look at
different Christians there's one group
of Christians primarily those who call
themselves fundamentalists or the far
wing of the Christian Right who believe
that the Bible is word-for-word the
literal words of God but there's a
second group of Christians typically you
find them amongst mainline protestants
and roman catholics etc who say well the
Bible was inspired by God but it was
funneled through human beings and so
their personal historical context etc we
have to take that into account but the
basic message the inspiration is from
God even though we can't take things
literally word for word so you believe
this actually yes yes okay and now did
your obviously belief change once you
finished seminary school oh absolutely
what did you think then well again when
you're when you're confronted with the
variances and what the original text
said and what the Bible says now as you
read it as I said before that that's a
shocking experience
and it causes one to question you know
what else is here that has been changed
where I don't have the original text
anymore
so I don't know that this change is
taking place yeah you know it's we know
what we know but how many other places
there may have been changes we don't
know now
did you lose a lot now we're gonna get
into and again people want to know the
big question why why did you accept
Islam why did you come to be a Muslim
we're going to get today we just want to
lead to that did you ever get people who
came to you with a confused look on your
face about this Trinity wanting to know
a little more adamantly how they could
make this fit God being obviously 3 and
1 is that correct father son and the
goals but not three but one and somebody
just came to you say pastor did they
call you what was the tight they call
you pastored or wherever Pastor Dirk's
can you please explain to me I can't
figure this out who do I pray to that I
prayed for the Father the Son the Holy
Ghost did you have these experiences not
that often and the reason for that again
is you know people are taught in Sunday
school they're taught in church from a
very early age you know God is three
persons in one substance mm-hmm as the
traditional Protestant and Roman
Catholic formulation of the Trinity some
of the Eastern Churches say three
substances and one essence yes but this
becomes a catchphrase free persons in
one substance you don't think about it
you don't question it it's just sort of
an automatic response if you're asked
about the Trinity you say uh three
persons in one substance three persons
being the Father the Son and the Holy
Ghost and so people tend to accept this
because it was ingrained at a very early
age mm-hmm they tend not to question it
or say now wait a minute exactly what
does that mean and when people do those
few who do typically they find that they
can't make any sense out of it mhm
in fact athenais Shizu was in many ways
the father
of the doctrine of the Trinity is
reported to have said very late in life
as he was dying that the more he thought
about the notion of the Trinity the less
sense it made to him hmm
so this is a very confusing issue and I
think most Christians typically avoid it
yes
they've just fall back on that early
learning of saying three persons in one
substance and if there's any questioning
that goes beyond that the response as
well that's one of the divine mysteries
what about the egg shell the yolk or the
water and it being three components one
part have you gotten this oh the sort of
thing about compare the Trinity to h2o
which of the steam water or ice mm-hmm
yeah I've gotten that the interesting
thing is that's actually officially a
heresy in traditional Christian thought
because you're denying the three persons
yeah most Christians who try to grapple
their way to some understanding of the
Trinity that goes beyond simply saying
three persons and one substance without
realizing it often drift off into what
the church has already condemned as
heresy in terms of their understanding
of the Trinity yeah Wow this amazing we
are almost out of time for this session
we're gonna have to do a part two we
let's get a few more questions in again
we're excited and we want to know like
what led up to finally accept in Islam
but we want to dig a little more to find
out some of the things that unique
experiences that you did you had did you
used to sing no I know I see a lot of
singing going on terrible sense of pitch
okay now tell us what did you believe
now you found these things you went from
believing that this the Bible which you
were brought up reading studying
learning was the Word of God correct and
now you go through this now what did you
believe did you believe that there was
still some of the Word of God in it and
it was man's adding deleting yeah
certain certainly I believe there there
was divine inspiration in the by
in places yeah I also realized that
there were corruptions of the Bible in
places I believe very strongly that
there was God yes and only one God but I
had no belief in the divinity of Jesus
Christ peace be upon him I had no belief
in the doctrine of the Trinity I had
serious questions about the crucifixion
event so I was basically from the time I
left the active ministry in 1974 until I
became a Muslim many years later what I
called an atypical Christian mm-hmm
what's a typical question well for me a
typical Christian is someone who doesn't
believe in the divinity of Jesus who
rejects the notion of the Trinity but
still maintains a deep and abiding
belief in God and who still you know
picks up the Bible reads it for the good
moral instruction that is found in it in
many places and continues to study the
Bible continues for example for me going
down to the local seminary and haunting
the bookstore and purchasing new books
on recent archeological finds having to
do with various texts of the Bible etc
did you find yourself getting in some
dialog for the people who believe
staunchly that no no no Jesus is God
that he is the son of God also and that
he died for your sins since obviously
now you didn't you had the antithesis of
this you would believe something
opposite to it did you have some
conflict here with other peers or
members of your congregation or friends
or well no no real conflict and in fact
I didn't attend church yeah very much at
all this is later on not that you know
once I left the ministry you know a few
times a year that would be it primarily
because I thought it was an important
family function to do but typically I
would go I would listen to a sermon I
would grit my teeth as I heard things I
knew we're not true give us an example
giving us a sample
well the Trinity yes for example or the
divinity of Jesus peace be upon him
or are some of the statements that were
made about the crucifixion or the
doctrine of the atonement and the blood
you're sitting there just like how can
they preach this yeah exactly
exactly this is amazing well what it is
a lot of Ministers yeah
rationalize uh-huh and they say I know
what I mean when I say the son of God
uh-huh and I understand it this way in
sort of a metaphorical way or I
understand it as I believe the actual
disciples understood that term or as it
was understood in first century
Palestine
however the congregation probably
doesn't yeah
understand it that way when that phrase
is said did you feel like this also went
against your very nature this inherent
nature that God put in all of us to
recognize the truth did you feel that
something inside you said no sure yeah
and do you feel like a lot of people
that they that you know you said a
typical Krish I've come across and these
are our brothers in human humanity yes
and we are to be the kindness to them
and we are to share this way of life
that we believe that all the messengers
of God they lived which was surrender
and submission obedience sincerity and
in peace which is something one word
Islam to share with them we don't have
to press the little ties and you know
try to twist ours accept it but if they
want to hey it's there for you sure it's
a way of life that God has ordained for
everybody take it if not you can lease
understand us and we can be brothers
working together for some kind of good
now tell us before we got like two
minutes and we're gonna have to do a
part two this is so exciting
tell us now did you feel that you now
because a lot of these people you said a
typical I'll come across people like I
was saying that they are Christian but
they don't believe Jesus is God other
people believe that he's son of God not
God there's some confusion here did you
at any time feel like you know what
confused now lost what do i do where do
I go from here well I think there are a
lot of atypical Christians out there
probably more among the ordained clergy
than among the laity because the
ordained clergy has been exposed
typically yeah to at least some of this
information mm-hmm
in fact there was a study done by
Psychology Today magazine back in the
early 1970s there was where they listed
what they considered to be ten
fundamental beliefs of Christianity and
they went out and surveyed the Christian
lady and found that on the average
Christian lady believed in about seven I
think it was of these ten yeah when they
surveyed the ordained ministry they
found they believed in about four uh-huh
of the ten yes oh you can see the
discrepancy this is not on it isn't it
that I don't know maybe in the 70s or
80s that the Anglican bishops they had
come to a unanimous decision that you
didn't to be a Christian you didn't have
to believe that Jesus was God also well
I'm not gonna speak for the Anglican
bishops yeah this is something that I
came across so it's not something odd
that people they also go with what's in
their nature and they reject this belief
that a man can be God that Jesus was God
etc that's true of a lot of people who I
would say are a typical Christian yeah
we are out of time we will inshallah
shall continue next week doing part two
because we didn't answer how you stumble
have you accepted submission to
surrender to the one God nothing in
creation but to the Creator who made the
Sun the moon who created Jesus who Jesus
prayed to actually didn't it yes okay we
could do the part too yes inshallah I'm
excited and I'm sure you're excited also
Thank You Jessica law hi to my brother
and jaeseok Lahari thank you so much for
being with us I know you're excited but
you know what we got to take a timeout
we've come and run out of time but next
week we're going to continue on and
we're going to answer this question why
Islam you got to hear a little bit about
the past
well dr. Dirk's going through Harvard
University going through the seminary
and being on the pulpit filling the
crowds with preaching the Bible but now
he's a Muslim and you want to know why
and we're going to bring you his story
insha'Allah God willing thank you we'll
see
next week here on the Dean show until
then assalamu alaikum peace be unto you
i want to be learning a shape on your
dream
mr. udon obi-wan super Hanukkah Femina
it's cold it's lay everybody sleeping I
arise and ask Allah to forgive me Omar
you see all our you know all the sins I
do I turn to you to pick it my sing
tomorrow I'm you seem for slave you
don't my love in Lord I'm the one runs
away all the guide me